elle devient la première femme à exercer
cette fonction amélie mauresmo a été
nommée directrice du tournoi de roland
garros en décembre dernier l'ancienne
joueuse détient l'un des plus beaux
palmarès du tennis français une
consécration ce tournoi m'a fait rêver
alors dès mon plus jeune âge il a ni
plus ni moins créer une vocation tout
simplement chez moi roland garros a été
un petit peu un fil conducteur sur toute
ma vie dans le sillage de l'ancien
numéro un mondial sabrina léger
s'affichant pionnière depuis plus d'un
an elle a pris les rênes de la ligue de
tennis de centre val de loire c'est la
première fois qu'une femme accède à ce
poste dans la région après de nombreux
mois en phase ii bat de campagne comme
toute campagne bah ça a été cerise sur
le gâteau avec une politique et un
programme sportif mis en place et avec
la volonté de de toute une équipe donc
ça c était plutôt c'est un sport
individuel mais avec un esprit d équipe
en plus de ses responsabilités
sabrina léger continue de fréquenter les
cours de ses débuts dans un club en
eure-et-loir jusqu'à la plus haute
fonction régionale elle continue le
tennis en compétition pour désormais
concilier vie professionnelle et passion
pour son sport
l'avantagent que j'ai d'être présidente
et je sais que je me déplace quand même
dans pas mal de clubs donc j'entends
j'écoute et je remonte les infos par
rapport au tennis féminin et ce
qu'attendent les femmes est en effet
l'organisation pour une femme est
beaucoup plus compliqué quand elle fait
un tournoi que pour un homme donc
trouver des solutions sur des tournoi
multichances choses comme ça où on
bloque qu'un week-end et je pense que
l'objectif il est là sur le circuit
féminin il faut aussi savoir s'imposer
berti landry est l'une des meilleures
joueuses de la région est pourtant
difficile encore de trouver sa place en
tant qu'entraîneur et se sentir légitime
du mal à nous sentir
je veux dire regardez on a l'impression
que battant entraînée par une fille
ténue voilà c'est pas jouer après quand
à un certain niveau tu peux avoir
certains travail que tu as pas
auparavant et aussi pour ça que j'ai
préféré me consacrer sur ma carrière de
joueuse pour après avoir une certaine
crédibilité dans mon travail plus tard
à bourges dans le deuxième plus gros
clubs de la région marielle sergent a
elle aussi briser le plafond de verre
est balayée d'un revers les préjugés
jamais une femme n'avait occupé la
présidence du club berruyer développer
le tennis féminin fait partie de ses
priorités avec notamment des tournoi
multichances dédié aux femmes
sur les tmc que nous avons organisé
cette année on a des femmes qui ont fait
leur premier match et qui sont donc
venus à la compétition en découvrant en
découvrant le tennis et forme de
compétition attractive on va partir sur
le même travail que ces dernières
semaines vous serez pas surprise on va
continuer à travailler beaucoup de
répétitions au service en septembre
dernier cet entraîneur a créé une équipe
de femmes tourné vers la compétition
tous les vendredis soir elles se
regroupent pour deux heures de pratique
les fans je sentais qu'il y avait une
demande mais qui effraient un peu les
aînés c'est ce qui est ressorti en fait
quand j'ai fait mon enquête en début de
saison et bah ouais ça m'intéresse mais
je sais pas forcément comment je
m'inscris un tournoi j'ose pas trop et
en quelques mois certaines d'entre elles
ont gagné jusqu'à six classements
dans l'ensemble on est toutes assez
solidaires assez contente de se
retrouver on va souvent voir les matches
des autres on s'encourage
on joue aussi en équipe seule ombre au
tableau le manque de joueuses en 4e
série qui empêche de diversifier les
rencontres on voit qu'au final on joue
tout le temps les mêmes filles quel que
soit le tournoi auquel on s'inscrit donc
c'est quand même qu'il ya encore du
travail à faire pour qu'ils aient plus
de gens et et qu'on puisse avoir plus de
variété au niveau des tournois en france
les femmes représentent toujours moins
d'un tiers des licenciés mais grâce au
travail entre la fédération les ligues
et les clubs le tennis se féminise et
les actions se multiplient pour pouvoir
viser encore plus haut